[MUSIC PLAYING]
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
The sound seems to be on.
Hello everyone.
I'm Mykola.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: And I'm Cezary.
Hello.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY:
First things first,
take advantage of the Dory Q&A
feature in your Cloud Next app
to ask questions that you
might have during the session
and to vote for the questions
that sounds interesting to you.
And in the end, it will
take a little bit of time
to answer some of the
questions on the top.
So please raise your hands.
How many of you run workloads
on multiple virtual machines?
The majority of people.
And how many of you
do any kind of batch
computation on
multiple machines?
Also quite a few.
And how many of you have at
least one virtual machine
on Compute Engine?
Pretty much most of the people.
Awesome.
So let's see how it works.
When you deploy a
new application,
you would probably
start with one machine,
deploy application to this
machine, test it, run it,
and you might have a few users.
This setup is quite
easy to manage manually.
Or maybe not that easy.
How do you know what
machine type to pick?
How much CPU or
memory do you need?
You probably could take
the same machine size
as you use in your on-prem
data center before,
but Compute Engine
allows you fine,
granular configuration
of how many CPU cores
or how much memory you can pick.
There is a good chance that
there is a machine type that
is just as well fit
for your workload,
but is smaller and cheaper.
How do you know that
you don't waste money?
And once your workload grows
and you get more users,
you will need multiple
machines to run it.
This is where all kinds
of problems might start,
and it is no longer feasible to
manage this type of Setup menu.
Let's look at what kind of
problems those could be.
First of all, your application
might stop responding or crash.
Some of the users might
experience interruptions
or latencies in your service.
Another problem is in the rare
event a whole zone might fail,
and if you have deployed all
your machines in a single zone,
your customers might
experience complete outage.
This is not something that
you want to experience.
Or your load might
spike and land
an insufficient number of
VMs, and the extra customers
that you have again might
experience longer latency
or not be served at all.
Something you don't
want to happen.
Or maybe you have provisioned
enough of the machines
to serve even your
highest peaks, but then
what when the weekend comes, for
example, and your usage drops?
You don't want to overpay for
all those extra machines that
are sitting idle.
And on top of all of
that, you will probably
continuously improve
your application
and run all kinds of updates.
Security patches, new features.
How do you roll out the updates
safely and avoid the disruption
in case of a bad
update for users?
When any of these
problems happen,
you don't want to
get paged, especially
in the middle of the night.
Because when coming to Cloud,
you expect your infrastructure
to run flawlessly.
And the good news is that
managed instance groups
and Compute Engine allows you
to take care of these problems
automatically and build
you highly available,
scalable applications where
you can roll out updates
automatically and
safely, and also pick
the optimal size of the
machines for your workloads.
So that you can
have a peace of mind
knowing that your
application is taken care of.
In today's session, we will look
how to deploy an application
to a managed instance group.
We'll build a stateless
load-balanced application.
And we will also look into
how to apply VM rightsizing
recommendations
to those machines.
And if you're already familiar
with some of these concepts,
we'll have our pro tips for you.
So let's start with the
application deployment.
You likely have some
kind of CI/CD pipeline
which results in an artifact.
You could package your
application in container image
or perhaps prebake
it together with all
of the dependencies on
the boot disk image,
or maybe write a
startup script on top
of a plain vanilla
operating system
so that it loads and boots
your application on VM start.
Any of these approaches
work with what we're
going to talk about today.
But for the sake of example,
let's pick container image.
Deploying container image
is easy on Compute Engine
and takes only two steps.
You create an instance, just as
you would in your regular VM.
You click the checkbox that
you want to deploy container.
Specify which container to run,
and some of the parameters.
Let's say, restart policy, or
you could pass some environment
variables to your container.
And what happens is
that our Compute Engine
will create virtual
machine based
on the container optimized
operating system image, which
already has Docker and container
startup agent pre-installed.
And it will boot your container
on VM start automatically.
You don't need to write
a new startup script.
And on top of that, whenever
you create a new machine
you could use the latest
version of the container image
with all of the updates
and security patches
that are managed by Google.
So if one machine
is not enough, you
can also deploy your
application to multiple machines
in a managed instance group.
So the way you do it is that
you create instance template
in exactly the same way as
it's for a virtual machine.
And then instance
template is like a recipe
for creating a machine that
managed instance groups uses
to create your VMs.
And if your application
is load balanced,
you can add your instance
group as a back-end service
to a load balancer.
That's it.
So let's see how it works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: OK.
So first we need to create
an instance template.
Before the presentation,
I've uploaded a container
to the Container Registry.
You can upload it using
Docker push command,
or just manually if you want.
So let's copy the
repository name.
Now let's create an
instant template.
Container.
Let's put the URL.
And also let's allow HTTP
traffic into the container
because we have a simple web
server application running
in this container.
So we can verify that
it's accepting traffic.
So right now we have
to wait few seconds
for the template to be created.
And once it's done, we can start
and create a managed instance
group using this template.
So let's call it container.
We can deploy it in
any zone you want.
You can turn off
autoscaling for now.
You can do this later.
And let's create.
So right now what is happening
is Google Compute Engine
is creating managed instance
group that will manage all
your instances within instance.
And right now, you'll see
that it's already created.
And you can see that there is
a new VM that it's starting.
So once it's been
created, we can verify
what is happening inside.
So let's go to the VM.
Let's go to the console.
And you can see that
all the commands
that are running
during the [INAUDIBLE],,
so it's being set up.
The IP is being
applied to the VM.
So OK.
We can also see right there--
OK.
Let's refresh.
So what is happening
in the background
that our VM is
pulling the container,
you can see it right here.
It's pulling the container
from the registry.
It's starting.
And once it's started,
it will boot up
and you can verify that
it's working by entering
the IP address and the URL.
And we can see that it's
up and running and serving
our web application
within a few minutes.
Like [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks.
Can you get back to
the slides, please?
Thank you.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: Yeah.
So we have deployed a
simple stateless application
to an instance group.
But now how do we make it
highly available and scalable?
But let's first talk about what
a stateless application is.
A good example of it would
be, for example, the front end
of a web store.
You want it to be
highly available
so that your customers don't
get HTP-500 during checkout
process, and you want
it to be scalable
so that you can get all
the business you can,
even during the spikes,
such as on Black Friday.
And stateless VMs are
like a herd of sheep.
You care only about
how many you have.
You can easily replace
one with another.
And the machines work
exactly the same way
and they don't care
any state on them.
So let's go back to the
problems that might happen.
What if application stops
responding or crashes?
I see you have a question there.
Could you put it on Dory?
And then we'll
address it in the end.
So if the application stops
responding or crashes,
autohealing will help
to take care of that.
It will automatically
recreate the instances.
It will detect that
they have failed,
and automatically
recreate them to keep them
in service so that your
customers can be served again.
Configuring autohealing is easy.
All you need to do is
to create a health check
and attach it to the
managed instance group.
And the way the
health checking works
is that it pings
your application
on a regular basis in the
specified port and protocol,
let's say HTTP 80, on
the paths that you show,
and it will expect
HTTP 200 response
that everything is OK
within a predefined latency
that you can configure.
And if the health check fails
multiple times in a row--
and again, you can configure
how many times this is,
let's say two failures--
then the instance
is deemed unhealthy and
autohealing will kick in
to recreate it from the instance
template with the well test
configuration.
And health checking
works for both HTTP,
HTTPS protocols, as
well as TCP and SSL.
What's important
to note is that you
can create exactly
the same health checks
for load balancing purposes.
And load balancer users
health checks differently
than managed instance groups.
When the VM is
marked as unhealthy,
load balancer does not send
new traffic to the machine,
and will send it to
the other machines that
are still healthy.
At the same time,
managed instance group
will recreate a machine that
isn't healthy to bring it back
in service.
These are very
different actions.
And for that reason,
we highly recommend
you to create different health
checks for a load balancer
and for managed instance group,
and make health checks more
aggressive for a load balancer.
More aggressive meaning
shorter check intervals,
expect lower response
latency, and maybe
a lower number of
failed health checks
to actually mark it unhealthy.
This is important because
imagine a situation when you
have a machine that is
serving at its full capacity,
so it cannot really receive
more traffic and will produce
latencies.
You want the load balancer
to redirect this traffic
to other machines.
At the same time, the
machine is perfectly
healthy, it's serving
existing connections,
so you don't want the autohealer
to kick in and recreate it.
So to make sure that
in such situation
your machine is
not recreated, you
should give autohealer a little
bit more time for the machine
to recover and
start serving again.
Or if it's really unhealthy
for a longer period,
only then recreate it.
That's why you need
two health checks.
Another pro tip is that, when
you configure autohealing,
make sure you set initial
delay to a higher value
than it takes for
your machine to start.
During the initial
delay, autohealing
will not touch
unhealthy machines
to give enough time for
the application to boot.
Of course, while
VM is booting, it
will be unhealthy because your
application is not yet serving.
So if you set initial delay to
longer than it takes to serve,
for the application
to start serving,
you will make sure that
autohealing will only
recreate a machine when
it is really unhealthy
and not because
it's still booting.
So let's see how all
autohealing works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: All right.
So we have an instance group
with three VMs up and running.
All of the VMs are running
the same web application.
This is a simple Python script.
It has a few features.
One of the features is
reporting the health status
of an application.
So if we click here, we can
verify that our application
is up and running.
It's serving HTTP 200 response.
So it's basically saying
to the managed instance
group, that, yes.
I'm OK.
I can accept traffic,
and I can serve traffic.
So what I did is I created
a simple method that
will just start reporting
unhealthy status.
So what it means is that
once I open the same URL,
it's basically
saying, I'm sorry.
I've crashed.
I will not accept any--
I should not accept any
connections right now.
So it's telling
managed instance group
that this VM is not responding.
The application is not running.
So it should be recreated.
Let's go here.
It usually takes a minute or
two for the managed instance
group to notice it.
So let's go and look how the
health check is configured.
So we've set up the
health check, autohealing.
So let's go to
the health checks.
Autohealing.
So we can see that it's
looking at the path /health.
So it's the same that
I've used previously.
It's using the HTTP
protocol on port 80.
It's pinging that application
every five seconds,
and it's waiting to for
two consecutive failures
to notice that it's unhealthy.
Let's go back to our
managed instance group.
Autohealing.
And you can see that managed
instance group detected
that an application crashed
and that the VM should
be recreated, and it's
already recreating.
So after a minute it
will be up and running,
and your VMs will
accept traffic,
and everything will be fine.
Can you switch back
to slides, please?
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So we have just
protected our application
against failure on
a single machine.
But what if there is
a more rare event when
there is a misconfiguration
or something happens
and the whole zone is out?
Autohealing will not
help you with that,
because even if it tries
to recreate the machines,
the problem is not
on the machine.
It's on the zonal level.
So in order to protect
your workload against that,
you can deploy your
machines to multiple zones
in the region using regional
managed instance groups.
And in this example,
the way it works
that even if a
single zone fails,
the load balancer will send
traffic to the other zones
where the machines
are still available,
and your customers
will still be served.
It's worth noting
that on this picture,
though, that you lose one
third of your capacity.
So let's say if you
need nine VMs to serve
all of your traffic, if a
zone fails, you get only six.
So if you want to really
have enough capacity to, even
in case of a zone failure,
to serve all of your users,
you should provision extra VMs
so that 2/3 of the total number
is enough to serve the traffic.
So in this example, for
example, if you deploy,
let's say six extra VMs,
even if a single zone fails,
you'll still have 10 VMs, which
is more than enough to cover
your requirement of 9.
And the way to calculate how
many extra VMs to provision
is easy.
You just divide the
number of total VMs
that you need to serve
your workload by the number
of the remaining serving zones.
So for example, if you deploy
your group to three zones,
you need to provision
50% extra machines
so that even in case
of zone failure,
you have enough machines to
serve all of your traffic.
So let's see how this works.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: OK.
So we have another
managed instance group.
This time it's deployed
in three different zones.
You can verify it here that it's
deployed in US central-1 b, c,
and f.
And in each zone, we have two
instances that are running.
I've also configured
a load balancer
that will direct traffic
to all of the instances.
Let's go open it up.
And you can see that on each--
refresh should work.
Just [INAUDIBLE] one more time.
Yeah.
On each refresh we
get a VM that is
serving from a different zone.
So what I did is I
wrote a simple script.
HTML.
That will just scrub the web
page from each of the instance,
get the zone that the
instance is running in,
and it will print
it on the screen.
So you can see that right
now, we have instances
serving from all of the zones.
So how to do tests on the--
how to test if the zone fails.
So I cannot bring the
whole zone down, obviously,
but what I can do is I can
simulate it by disabling health
checks.
Sorry, not disabling, like--
start making our VMs report
unhealthy from particular zone.
So let's do that.
[INAUDIBLE]
Disable US central-1.
Perfect.
All right.
So what I did, as I told you,
right now, VMs from zone F
are starting to report
that are unhealthy.
So load balancer will notice
it in a matter of seconds
and will start
directing traffic.
You can already see
that we are serving
traffic only from zone
B and zone C. So let's
also disable zone B.
Few more seconds.
All right.
You can see that load balancing.
Notice it.
And right now we are
serving only from zone C.
So let's bring
back all the zones.
Back up.
That's right.
US central-1.
All right.
So all the VMs are
reporting healthy.
So load balancer
pings each of the VMs.
Notice that it's starting
to report healthy
and it can accept traffic,
and will start directing
the traffic back to those VMs.
You already see that
zone B is up and running,
and zone F will be available
in a matter of seconds.
Can we get back to
the slides, please?
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So now we have a highly
available application.
We've protected it against
the application failure
in the single machines, and
also against the more rare event
of a whole zonal failure.
But how about the problems
when a load spikes?
Or when you have
a load going down
and excess VMs that you
don't want to pay for it?
Autoscaling helps you with that.
It maintains the group size
tailored to the current load
that your service experiences.
Configuring autoscaling is easy.
You set up the load metric
on which you want to scale.
A very popular one is
CPU usage, for example.
You set the target load.
Let's say at 60%.
You can also specify a minimum
and maximum number of VMs
that autoscaler
should not exceed.
Minimum is useful if you want
to have the minimum capacity
that you always
want to be running,
and maximum is to
essentially cap
your budget against the scale up
if you don't want to overspend.
And also you need to
specify a cooldown period.
During the cooldown
period, it starts
when the VM boots and expires
after the number of seconds
you specify.
Autoscaler ignores the
signal from this machine.
This is because on VM
boot, the signal might not
reflect the actual
real life load,
as many of the
boot processes can
utilize CPUs more than usual.
So make sure you configure a
cooldown period to a higher
value than the VM takes to boot
so that your Autoscaler takes
only the signal that
represents the actual load,
and hence makes more
accurate scaling decisions.
So let's see how
Autoscaling works.
Let's say you have three
overloaded machines
and a target load of 60%.
Autoscaler will notice
that the average load
is way above the target,
and will create two more
machines to bring the average
load back to the target.
Now, if the load
goes down over time,
Autoscaler will notice again
that the average is now
significantly lower
than the target
and will remove the extra
machines to bring it back
to the target.
That's how it works
in a nutshell.
And pro tip is that if
you want to make sure
that your workload
scales up really fast,
you should use a
lower target CPU load.
If we look at the
example here, if you
have three overloaded
machines of, let's say,
80%, 70%, and 90% utilization,
if you set the target
load at 60%, Autoscaler
will scale the group size
to four machines.
And if you set the target
lower to a lower value,
like, say, 40%, you
will get six machines,
which is a faster scale up.
And one more tip.
If you use Autoscaling with
regional managed instance
groups, the same
approach applies
as for fixed size groups
which are not autoscaled.
Make sure that you set
maximum number of instances
to a higher value that is
needed to serve your load so
that, even if a whole
zone failure happens,
Autoscaler has enough room to
scale up in the other zones.
The formula for
calculating how much extra
to set for the maximum is the
same as for the fixed size.
The only difference is that
in the fixed size group,
you will have these
machines always running,
whereas in Autoscaled group
you don't have to pay for them.
This is only a
theoretical maximum
that you allow your
Autoscaler to reach.
So let's look at
Autoscaling in practice.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: OK.
So we have one VM that is
running the same web server
application.
So I told you that
this web server
has a few different features.
So one was reporting how
healthy or unhealthy status.
The second one is making
the high load on the CPU.
So what it does
in the background
is just multiplying to
run the numbers in a loop
without any delay.
So it's basically making the
CPU being utilized in 100%.
Let's look how our
Autoscaling is configured.
So we are looking
at the CPU usage.
And we want to have
our managed instance
group scaled to be below 50% on
average usage of all the VMs.
Minimal number of
instances is one.
That's why you saw one
instance up and running.
And we have maximum number
of instances set to five,
and cooldown periods
set to 30 seconds, which
means that Autoscaler will not
look at the CPU utilization
for the first 30 seconds.
Our application is quite small.
It starts quite fast.
But if you have very
high, intensive workloads,
for example, creating
cache or something else,
you can put a
bigger number here.
Let's go back.
OK.
You can already see that--
can we get them
back to the screen?
OK.
You can already
see that Autoscaler
noticed that this first
VM was over-utilized
and started to boot
up additional VMs.
If those VMs will be also
utilized in over 50%,
Autoscaler will schedule
another VM creation
and bring it up to number five.
Thank you.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So now we have a highly
available Autoscaled
application.
But how about updates?
How do you roll out the
updates automatically but also
protect your customers
against bad pushes which
sometimes happens?
Autoupdater allows
you to do just that.
But before we go into
how you configure it,
let's think about
what an update is.
In the beginning, you
have an instance group
in an old version.
At the end, you want to
have it in the new version.
And update is a
journey of how you
get from the old
version to a new one,
as it takes multiple steps.
And you can
configure the journey
with the following parameters.
First, you can set up how many
machines you want to update.
Maybe you want to
update the whole group
if this is an urgent fix.
Maybe you want to
do a canary update
and update only part of it.
So let's say you roll out
to half of the group to see
how it works before proceeding.
Second parameter is
how many machines
do you update at the same
time as the machines need
to be recreated
from a new instance
template for an update.
So this is your
disruption budget.
Third parameter is how many
extra VMs in the new version
to add temporarily
for the update?
This is useful if you don't want
to take any of the old machines
down, but keep them in
service and instead create
new machines and new
versions in the new version.
Wait until they start
serving, and only then take
down the old ones.
Finally, you can specify
the minimum wait time,
which is after the
machines have been updated,
how long to wait
before proceeding
to the next batch in
the rolling update.
You can also use Recreate or
Restart actions for an update.
Recreate is when you recreated
from the new instance template.
Restart is useful
when you use an agent
inside a machine for
an update and you
need to restart to
actuate that update.
With the same rollout
logic as above.
And finally, you can make
an updater proactive, which
means that it will do the
rolling update automatically,
or opportunistic, which
means that it will only
create new machines
when they are needed.
For example, when scaling up.
And it will only delete the old
machines when also it's needed.
For example, if you
resize the group down.
And you can have even
more fine-grained
control over update,
for example, which
specific machines to update,
when, in which order,
by setting the update
for opportunistic change
in the instance
template in the group
and then just recreate
in the machines
that you want to
update manually.
And on machine creation, they
will pick up the new instance
template and you will
get the new version.
This way, you can be in
full control of the rollout
if you don't want an
update to be automatic.
So let's look at some
of the common scenarios.
Rolling update is the first one.
So imagine you have a
quick fix that you need
to roll out to the whole group.
So you set a new
template to 100%.
However, to stay
on the safe side
and not to disrupt
the service too much,
you say that the roll out, let's
say, three machines at a time.
And if the update
is good, updater
will proceed with the
next three machines.
If it's bad-- bad means
it doesn't pass the health
checks--
the updater will stop.
And then you can
come and check out
what's happening in the back or
maybe make a rollback decision.
But if everything is
going well, the updater
will take three machines
by three machines
until the whole
group is updated.
And it will only proceed
to the next batch of three
once the previous three have
passed the health checks.
Another very common
scenario is canary update.
So imagine you have a web
store, and you roll out
an update that is supposed
to increase conversion
to purchases.
Of course, you are not going to
roll out it to the whole group
right away.
You'll probably wants to
canary it, let's say to 30%,
and wait for a while.
Maybe a week, maybe a month,
to collect enough data
to prove that the conversion
is indeed improved.
And roll it forward
if that's the case,
or roll back if
it didn't happen.
So let's have a look.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: OK.
So let's do both things
at the same time,
both things what Mykola said.
So let's do a canary update
and a rolling [INAUDIBLE]..
So we have four VMs.
All of these are created
from the instance template 1.
Before I will start
the rollout process
I need to tell you a few
words about this application.
It's a simple
application that monitors
the internal status of the VM.
So it will show you
when the VM will
start creating, when it's
going to be deleted, when
it's restarting, recreating.
And it will also show you
the version of the template
that it's used to create.
So you can see that we have four
application, four VMs running
from instance template 1.
So now let's
initiate the update.
Let's say we want to have
half of our fleet serving
from new version
of the application.
And we'll also want to spin
up one new VM at a time.
So what it means
that we will not
exceed the number
five of VMs that
are running at the same time.
All right.
OK.
You can see right now that
the new VM is being created.
It usually takes about 30 to
45 seconds for the process
to be completed.
So we need to wait a bit.
Once this VM is up and running,
and managed instance group
verified that it's
created successfully,
one of the older VMs that
were created using instance
template version
1 will be deleted.
Once this VM, the deletion
process will be completed,
will spin up additional
VMs, additional one VM.
So you will see another
bar with a green color,
and the process continues.
So right now, you can see
that the instance is created.
It's created from the
version template 2.
So we have a new application,
new version application
running on the VM.
And once the process is
completed, one of the older VMs
was starting to be deleted.
And as I said, the process will
continue once half of the fleet
will be served from the manual
version of the applications.
Back to you, Mykola.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: Yeah.
And what's great to
note is that when
you do a canary update, let's
say to half of the fleet,
even if the group is autoscaled,
it will automatically
maintain this ratio for you
if you specify a percentage.
But you can also specify
a fixed number of VMs
and canary one, or two,
or three VMs as you wish.
So another interesting scenario
that is worth looking at
is if you have a highly
available workload
that you really don't
want to disrupt at all,
but you want to roll out update
as quickly as possible, you
can set the new
template to 100%,
so you want to update
the whole group.
But you set max
unavailable to zero
so that none of the old
serving VMs is touched,
and instead max surge to 100%.
So what's going to
happen is that the group
will create 100% more
VMs in the new version,
wait until those VMs
pass the health checks,
and only then remove
the old version.
So this way you get
highly available update,
but which is fast
at the same time.
So how does updater coordinate
with the other automation
services?
Let's say updater
and autohealing.
You have specified that your
disruption budget is two,
so you can update two
machines at a time,
take them out of service, and
updater successfully did that.
Now, as the updater is about
to get to the next batch,
one of the old machines fails.
Autohealing will detect that
and will start recreating it.
But will updater take
down two more machines,
or one for an update?
The good news is that updater
is aware of the disruption
and will respect your
configuration of max
unavailable 2, and will take
only one extra machines down
for an update so that
your workload is still
serving at the capacity
that you can tolerate.
And in the end, the one machine
gets updated and another one
gets autohealed.
How about updater
and autoscaling?
Let's say updater recreates two
machines from the new instance
template.
And of course, while these
machines are being recreated
they remain in the VM so
we'll get a bit more traffic.
And the average CPU
load will spike.
Will autoscaler
create extra machines?
The answer is no.
Autoscaler is aware that the
machines that are being updated
will be back up
and running soon,
so it will keep the group
size at the same value.
And once the machines are
back, it will be serving again.
How about updater and regional
managed instance group?
Updater will update the
machines evenly across the zones
to spread the risk.
And once the new machines
are up and running,
it will also remove
the old machines
evenly across the zones again
to spread the risk for you,
for high availability.
Finally, let's have
a look at how updater
works with a load balancer.
So before taking and recreating
a machine for an update,
the machine will first
stop receiving new traffic.
Then it will wait for a
connection draining time out
to drain the active sessions.
You can configure it in your
load balancer configuration.
And only once the
sessions are drained,
updater will recreate the
instance from the new template,
wait until it becomes healthy.
And after that, the new machine
will start serving traffic.
So the updater's
really very graceful
and won't interrupt any of
the existing connections.
So there we have it.
Managed instance groups allow
you to build highly available,
scalable applications that are
easy to update automatically,
and will take care of
application failure
with autohealing, will
protect your application
against zonal failure
by distributing machines
across multiple zones,
will also tailor group
size to the variable
load with autoscaling,
and also protect updates
from unhealthy new versions,
but if the machines are healthy,
roll it out automatically
so that you can
have peace of mind
and focus on your
more important tasks
knowing that your
workload is taken care of.
Now let's have a look at the
rightsizing your machines.
We've talked about that it's
not very easy to pick up
the right shape for a machine.
Of course, the shape
that you have used back
in your on-prem data
center will work,
but there are many more
potentially possible
combinations of CPU
cores and memory
that are available
on Compute Engine.
So how do you know
that you don't overpay?
The good news is that Compute
Engine observes utilization
of a CPU and memory
in your machines
over the eight
days period, which
is good if your workload
has a weekly load patterns
or more or less persistent
or load over time.
And will recommend
the optimal size
for your machine if it thinks
that the current size is not
optimal, either for
individual machines
or for VMs in the managed
instance groups that are not
autoscaled horizontally.
And recommendation can
be either save money
if your machine is too
big, or, if it consistently
sees that the utilization,
for example, is very high,
it might suggest you to get
a bigger machine to improve
performance of your workload.
And what's great is that we have
the Recommendations API already
available in Alpha,
which allows you
to get all of the
recommendations
from your projects
programmatically via RESTful
API.
And then with the data,
you can aggregate, triage,
prioritize the
recommendation as it
makes sense for
your organization,
build dashboard
supports for your teams,
visualize savings, and
whatnot to help you manage
the costs of your deployments.
And one more pro
tip is that if you
want more accurate
recommendations,
use Stackdriver monitoring
agent on your machines,
as it has a better
visibility into utilization
inside the machine.
And as a result will
increase quality
of the recommendations for you.
So let's have a look.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: All right.
We have five
different instances.
So let's imagine that you
have a virtual machine
on your own data
center, and you move it
to the GCP, the Google Cloud,
using the exact same size.
So for example, we have a
machine that has four CPU cores
and 50 gigabytes of memory.
But what happens if your
application does not
use this CPU power and memory?
We'll detect it,
and after one day,
we'll give you the
recommendation to size
it down to save some money.
So resizing the
VM is very simple.
You just click on the Resize.
You can customize the VM size.
For example, if you know that
your application will not even
use two CPUs as we
recommended, you
can even scale it down to
one CPU, and you click Apply.
So now what happens is we will
automatically stop the VM,
change the VM's
shape, and start it up
without you having
to do anything else.
But this is the one
type of recommendation.
So it's basically telling you,
size down to save some money.
But what if you've created a VM,
you've started the application,
and right now the application
is very high-CPU intensive?
For example you have this
web server application
that is doing some,
or workloads that
are doing the computations.
Again, we detected it.
We can verify that.
There is a process that
it's utilizing one hundredth
of the CPU all the time.
So we detected it.
And we are saying,
basically, your instance
is under-utilized, and
you should scale it up.
And you can apply the
same recommendations
in the same way.
So click Resize, change
the number of CPUs or RAM,
and be good.
The same thing who works
for managed instance groups.
So you can see that right now,
we have a managed instance
group with two instances.
And again, they have a
low memory usage, low CPU
utilization.
So you can change the instance
template to the smaller one
and save some money each month.
OK.
So I will now show you how
to quickly use the API.
So this is a simple one-line
code using [INAUDIBLE]
that will just query
the recommendations,
and will basically get the
same information that you've
seen on the screen.
So for example here, we can see
some information about the zone
and that we will save $74 US if
we apply these recommendations.
And using it, you can
build, as Mykola said,
a simple dashboard that will
aggregate all information
from all the VMs
in your projects
from all the projects
that are created by you.
For example, the sum and give
you the total savings per month
from all the recommendations
that you saw.
Can you get back to
the slides, please?
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
So in short, rightsizing
recommendations
help you to save costs
on your deployments,
improve performance, and
what's most important,
relieve you of the pain to
make the decision of what
machine size do you have.
There is no wrong decision.
Even if the machine
size is not optimal,
recommendations will
detect that based
on the utilization that
they observe and suggest you
a size that it thinks
might be a better fit.
So bring it all together.
We have looked at how
to deploy application
with the containers on
managed instance groups.
We've built highly available and
scalable stateless applications
on top of managed
instance groups.
And we have also
looked at how to apply
rightsizing recommendations
to your VMs.
And I want to leave
you with this,
that even if you have
to deploy your workloads
to virtual machines
to have full control
over your infrastructure, you
don't have to manage everything
by hand.
You can have highly scalable
and available deployments
by picking and choosing
recommendations,
as well as automated
services, such as autoscaling,
autohealing, autoupdating,
that work for you.
You are not on your own.
Thank you.
And just a quick
reminder, don't forget
to give the feedback
on the session, which
is available in your app.
CEZARY PIEKACZ: All right.
MYKOLA KOMAREVSKYY: All right.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]